qualche tempo fa è successa una cosa
secondo me simbolica un'azienda
molto importante internazionale che
produce filati in tutto il mondo ha
chiesto al proprio target di riferimento
principalmente donne tra i 25 e 40 anni
dove avessero imparato a lavorare a
maglia
la risposta nel 60 per cento dei casi è
stata youtube youtube è stata la nonna
della nostra generazione
in tutto il mondo giovani e meno giovani
hanno ripreso contatto con materiali di
utensili in maniera concreta cioè
facendo o soltanto con la loro
fascinazione tramite foto e video
prodotti e postati in tutto il mondo e
diffusi sui social network tendiamo ad
imitare ciò che vediamo questo rimettere
le mani in pasta in maniera così
generalizzata ha avuto diverse cause la
crisi economica e lavorativa in primis
ovviamente ma anche come clienti e come
designer una certa alienazione dovuta
un'offerta troppo standardizzata figlia
naturale della delocalizzazione
produttiva
tutto questo insieme a nuovi valori
ritrovate anche valori di ecologici
sociali ed etici non si è trattato
soltanto di un movimento dal basso
sempre nello stesso periodo la
manifattura è uscita dalle aziende dove
era stata rinchiusa negli ultimi anni è
resa qui meccanica e muta e
allontanandosi quindi dalla vita
quotidiana delle persone comuni per
ritornarne adesso con nuovi significati
nuove tecnologie nuove tecnologie e
nuovi prodotti
oggi ci troviamo paradossalmente other
aziende che aprono al pubblico come i
palazzi segreti delle giornate fai per
adesso soltanto in lombardia in piemonte
ma speriamo che venga presto in tutta
italia e accogliendo in quelle giornate
lo stesso tipo di interesse di
fascinazione workshop di qualsiasi tipo
di tecnologia
artigiana e aperitivo in cui ormai si
parla di tagli e cuci serigrafia e pasta
madre il fare è diventato di nuovo parte
della nostra quotidianità
ma il digitale non è stato soltanto
maestro ma anche e soprattutto vetrina
di vendita qui lo sappiamo bene
vetrina di vendita che nel tempo nuovi
brand e l'azienda un po più strutturate
hanno imparato e stanno imparando
tuttora rendere più personale più mirata
e di fatto rimettendo in piedi o
cominciando a rimettere in piedi un
intero indotto produttivo il saper
utilizzare gli strumenti digitali legati
alla comunicazione il postale di farsi
vedere e farsi notare postando delle
foto che siano emotivi emozionali
coinvolgenti ma allo stesso tempo
conoscendo tutta una serie di cose
riguardo le parole giuste da usare gli
orari e segreti di indicizzazione è
diventato nel tempo sempre sempre più
importante e nel frattempo la l'offerta
formativa su questo tipo di tematiche si
è moltiplicata a tutti i livelli quindi
abbiamo dai corsi on line ai workshop
professionali a consulenti nati proprio
da questo tipo di indotto certo che
l'unione di comunicazione digitale e
vendita online ha avuto tutta una serie
di ripercussioni molto importanti
prima di tutto il raggiungimento di
nuovi target e nick diffuse io prima
paradossalmente potevo arrivare a tutti
i clienti del mio territorio o dove
avevo dei negozi o una una rete
commerciale che arrivava appunto in
quella regione
adesso potenzialmente ovviamente arrivo
a chiunque possa essere interessato al
mio prodotto che sia da toronto a
pescara seconda cosa il coinvolgimento
il feedback
il fatto di avere un contatto diretto
con il proprio pubblico tramite
l'esposizione sui social network
mi permette di vedere il reale l'effetto
reale che il mio prodotto a sul mio
cliente quindi risolvere problematiche
poter accettare richieste di
personalizzazione ed avere in cambio
maggiore fidelizzazione e anche
soddisfazione personale e l'era del
coinvolgimento del dialogo diretto col
pubblico quale però il problema che
comunque dobbiamo farci vedere per farci
notare dobbiamo farci vedere l'immagine
è diventata tutto quello a cui ruota il
nostro mondo l'immagine è quella che ci
fa scegliere che ci fa affezionare un
brand che conferma la bontà della nostra
prima impressione e rafforza la
sicurezza che abbiamo rispetto a un
acquisto ma abbiamo pochissimo tempo per
farlo
una frazione di secondo il tempo che il
dito l'indice scorra dall'alto verso il
basso nel nostro fido di instagram e di
facebook il nostro cliente potenziale si
sofferma approfondisce qualità e
d'immagine reperibilità di un prodotto
costo e poi forse decide di seguirci e
forse ancora decide di acquistare per
colpire in questa frazione di secondo
così questa finestra così piccola ci sia
diretti verso un tipo di comunicazione
facile delle immagini facili
immediatamente riconoscibili
didascaliche già familiari quasi
predigerite non c'è tempo per un livello
successivo di comprensione
bisogna colpire farlo subito una
comunicazione con la data di la data di
scadenza già passata nella prima costata
fra qualche tempo ci ricorderemo di
questo periodo come quello dell'ansia
per la bella foto quante volte ce
l'hanno detto le belle foto delle
inquadrature dall'alto gli sfondi
bianchi le foto la storytelling con le
mani rugose e degli artigiani che
lavorano sui tavoli di legno per a
quella barba hipster dell'opa che
funziona perché già pensato come avatar
dell'ansia da condivisione ma in questa
corsa la comunicazione e qui arrivo al
punto quanto del nostro tempo dedichiamo
alla progettazione e al perfezionamento
del nostro oggetto di quello che stiamo
immettendo sul mercato in proporzione
poco pochissimo perché abbiamo fretta di
postare
il risultato sono prodotti tutti uguali
insipidi con loghi e foto meravigliose
raffinatissime ma tutti uguali
oppure prodotti auto referenziali con
target inesistenti ma postati con
hashtag e orari perfetti qui vedete tra
l'altro proprio prodotti carini ma
carino abbastanza è davvero abbastanza
l'immagine la cura dell'immagine è
fondamentale in questo periodo in cui
dell'era contemporanea appena
l'indifferenza del pubblico ovviamente
ma il prodotto la sua capacità di
parlare al pubblico che vogliamo
raggiungere tramite dettagli
interessanti e significativi la forte
idea che ha la sua base è una cosa
ancora più importante non possiamo
affettarla per l'ansia della
condivisione e del postare una nuova
foto
senonchè prodotto non ci ha senso
parlare di comunicazione e quello che
sembra prima o poi si dimostrerà quello
che ho passato gli ultimi dieci anni ad
osservare scrivere connettere far
crescere il mondo del nuovo artigianato
ed imprenditoria dai piccoli
autoproduttori a ai terzisti dei
distretti produttivi il percorso è stato
simile un'ubriacatura digitale così
forte da far perdere di vista
l'obiettivo che avevamo all'inizio
quello di far conoscere ed apprezzare il
nostro prodotto sul serio
il prototipo è tale proprio perché è
migliorabile
non abbiamo più tempo per provare e
cambiare le cose
abbiamo sempre l'ansia di condivisione
ed è una cosa che ci sta fregando
perdonate il senso per la qualità di
quello che stiamo facendo tutti i
prodotti del made in italy che più ci
ricordiamo che fanno parte della storia
di quello che ci riconoscono all'estero
che sia la moda il design p food sono
nati da una collaborazione una
collaborazione fra designer creativi
progettisti e maestranze dotate di un
enorme capacità e buon gusto che hanno
migliorato in corsa ogni prototipo il
campione questo mondo rischia di essere
completamente mandato allo sfascio per
un'attenzione eccessiva all'immagine
piuttosto che al prodotto e nel
frattempo creiamo di nuovo una distanza
con il nostro pubblico
questo tipo di distanza data da una
immagine perfetta e raffinata cui
abbiamo teso in questo periodo che però
da una parte ci rassicura perché di alta
percezione dall'altra ci fa perdere di
vista quella distanza quel dialogo
diretto scusate è quella piccola
imperfezione che nell'ultimo periodo ci
ha fatto di nuovo percepire come
autentici la differenza non possiamo più
puntare su quello che ci accomuna ma su
quello che ci differenzia facciamolo
come creativi come artigiani come
individui ricominciamo a progettare
prototipare a migliorare usiamo la
nostra creatività e il nostro
perfezionismo non soltanto sulla
comunicazione ma anche sul prodotto
perché quello che rimane dovete essere
voi stessi il vostro stesso mood il
vostro mood board di riferimento dovete
essere consapevoli non instagram abili
pieno di prodotti che non hanno un'anima
foto meravigliose up che cercano di
dimostrarci tutta la bellezza del
cambiare colore sfondo foto tutti uguali
di sfondi di legno sbiancato ultimamente
colori pastello
non è possibile non dare importanza a
queste cose nel mondo contemporaneo
perché se io soltanto una finestra di un
secondo
bisogna che mi faccio notare ma perché
da è tutta questa importanza solo
all'immagine e non ha tutto quello per
cui siamo famosi in tutto il mondo siamo
stati famosi in tutto il mondo
il contatto con i materiali il contatto
con gli utensili cambiare idea perché a
volte per non disturbare questa immagine
così faticosamente studiata e raffinata
abbiamo paura di cambiare idea di
evolversi verso altro anche se potrebbe
essere la cosa migliore da fare in quel
momento non possiamo essere più im
prigionieri dell'immagine questa
immagine così perfetta ci sta riportando
indietro è importante ancora una volta
dare la stessa importanza a quello che
facevamo prima
chiudete internet chiudete instagram e
ve lo dice una che sempre sulle stories
quindi proprio la progettazione va
raccontata alla fine quando siamo sicuri
noi non va condiviso il processo
produttivo
vi faccio un esempio secondo voi le
maestranze che hanno collaborato in
questi anni a creare dagli anni 60 in
poi i migliori prodotti del design che
ci conoscono in tutto il mondo se si
fossero fermati ilike sulla foto del
primo prodotto secondo voi avrebbero
condiviso avrebbero continuato a
migliorare il prodotto e avremmo adesso
i prodotti di qualità che conosciamo
nascondete i prodotti i prototipi
nascondete le prove
dovete essere convinti voi raccontare
nuovi prodotti raccontare prove
raccontare primi campioni da sicuramente
fascino al vostro feed e coinvolge ma
allo stesso tempo c
dopo la non condividete le prove non
condivido in condividete la
progettazione sto dicendo una cosa che
mi rendo conto che vi dicono l'opposto
di fare perché da fascino ma nel
frattempo abbiamo una rassicurazione
finta su dei prodotti che alla fine sono
solo primi abbozzi e la storia del made
in italy non è fatta di primi abbozzi
quindi siate il vostro stesso mood board
siate consapevoli e non siate instagram
abili grazie
[Applauso]